now it was of course the topic david
cameron warned his party some time back
to stop banging on abouts but the
clamors over europe have only got louder
and this week is of course crunch time
on thursday the prime minister will set
out his stall in brussels hoping for an
agreement on a package of reforms to
britain's relationship with the european
union well i'm joined now by one of the
most influential mps in parliament
graham brady as chair of the 1922
committee he is effectively the leader
of the conservative backbenchers now
very good morning to you mr brady right
well let's focus on brussels i mean is
it
i mean do you think it's really not
really worth bothering the prime
minister with this given you don't
really think that what he's got already
or the proto agreement with donald tusk
amounts to much i i think all the things
that david cameron's trying to get out
of the eu are good or positive things uh
but for many of us it just doesn't come
anywhere near to uh being sufficient i
wanted to see real
powers being brought back to british
control i wanted to see things taken out
of the hands of brussels and back in
british democratic control uh so
it doesn't come anywhere near that so
you kind of know he's not going to get
that because we as i say we saw one we
saw what he thrashed out with this is
down when he comes before his eu
partners who can say but as far as i'm
concerned what it doesn't constitute
even if he gets everything he's asking
for it isn't a fundamental change it
isn't the thing that brings real
democratic control back to the united
kingdom
restores our ability to decide who
governs us and to be able to kick people
out when we don't like them
but are there those that
perhaps didn't entirely support your
point of view thought okay
that's quite
quite a good agreement he he worked out
with the prime minister if they get
something like that then maybe i might
vote for him you're talking about my
colleagues i i certainly i never pretend
to speak for all of my background no
absolutely no no for equality especially
on this subject uh where there is a very
wide spectrum of views and of course
there'll be people who think that this
is a good deal but it's sufficient for
them
but i think many many people
in parliament and outside all over the
country are looking at this and thinking
is it really the fundamental change in
our relationship with the eu that we
wanted does it take us back
to what we thought we were joining 40
odd years ago does it take us back
to something which is really a trading
agreement and an ability to cooperate
with other sovereign states and clearly
it doesn't do that there is rumbling in
the background of all these negotiations
um noises coming from uh senior european
partners at the moment saying that there
will actually be be a price for the uk
should it
get agreement should it then vote to
remain within the european union that
you'll have to get more involved do you
have to become more of an active partner
well
the fundamental thing that we want and i
think i've always wanted with our
european partners is free and open trade
given that they sell more to us than we
sell to them i don't think there's any
danger of that free and open trade being
suspended they would be cutting off
their nose despite their face so i i
think it's a given that we would have
good open access to european markets
just as we would continue to allow good
open access to british markets for our
european uh partners but it's pretty odd
isn't it it's a pretty strange kind of
club
that we're a member of
if the other members as we try to change
our relationship are seeking to threaten
us it doesn't sound like such a good
arrangement as perhaps is sometimes
being suggested well the threats are not
just coming from our partners are there
i mean what do you think of the the
campaign because something clearly
underway at the moment you know there
are those uh on your side saying well
project fear has all ready started from
those that want us to remain within the
european union thinking about today's
story on the front of the sunday times
airfares will go up during the course of
last week we had five thousand migrants
will come here overnight yes from
california what do you make of this well
it's not so long ago that many of the
same people were telling us the british
economy would be finished if we didn't
join the euro so i think we should take
all of these things with a pinch of salt
but it is unfortunate i think that we're
not getting the kind of positive debate
that would be more welcome i think for
most of the british people and well
really
the question is is it a bigger leap in
the dark to stay in the european union
or are we taking a risk to to leave now
i think we know uh beyond doubt after
all of these decades of membership
that staying in the european union isn't
a
static position there's no status quo if
you're in this organization it carries
on integrating it carries on increasing
powers to itself it's done it throughout
its history uh it will continue to do
that but what those kind of stories do
tell us is is that it seems that
the stay in campaign and campaigns have
got their act together they're coming
across on an almost daily basis with a
different story whereas on the leave
side you've got various different
campaigns we know about the bickering
within the camps do you not think it
would be best to try and get one
organization to speak for you all well
of course we should have one
organization speaking for the leave
campaign i hope we'll get there soon i
hope that it'll happen uh through the
electoral commission uh getting on with
designation of a lead campaign we can
then all get on with the important thing
which is campaigning to restore british
democracy
but all of these campaigns all these
stories that have been coming out of the
campaign to remain
they may have been very good at
producing this copy but as soon as it
hits the front page as soon as it's on
the broadcast media it's all been
comprehensively rubbished so you know in
many ways i think the the more extreme
some of these stories become the more
the campaign to frighten people into
staying
gets into
into gear uh the more effectively it's
putting people off uh the european union
the more effectively it's making people
think there might be something a little
bit dodgy about this organization that
we're a member of and just um talk to me
about timings within your own party
within the government
after the brussels meeting should there
be a cabinet meeting as soon as possible
perhaps
next saturday to say to those that say
well prime minister you tried very hard
we appreciate all your efforts but you
didn't get enough please now let us
speak out to leave the european union i
think that's absolutely essential it's
in everybody's interest to do this as
quickly as possible and if it were to
appear that david cameron was seeking to
have the whole weekend to himself to put
one side of the argument
i think that would look bad for the
remain campaign people want an honest
fair
debate they want an honest fair campaign
so i think it's in the interest of both
sides to have that early cabinet meeting
and to make sure that people who want to
speak out uh people who want to exploit
that freedom of conscience that has
rightly been uh agreed uh can do so as
soon as possible that should take place
on saturday then uh well well let's look
at the timings if if you could take
place on friday evening that would be
even better okay and what about mr
cameron himself that poll uh out today
saying that you know he's been damaged
people losing confidence in mr cameron
on the eu negotiations i mean this is
the man of course you know won an
unexpected overall majority for your
party do you think it's chipping away at
him well i certainly think it's a
mistake to try to oversell this deal uh
it's very clear to everybody it's not a
fundamental change in our relationship
with the european union so mistake to
oversell it
but also looking at it in a more
positive way every time over the last
few years as prime minister david
cameron has done something on the
eurosceptic side every time he's stood
up for britain every time he has when he
vetoed the treaty when he managed to get
the eu budget capped uh all of those
occasions his popularity spiked uh so
let's hopefully draw an inference but i
mean you know he still technically could
uh could uh be against staying within
the european union very unlikely but if
he does campaign to remain and loses
that referendum as you would like to see
haven't you then ended his career i i
think uh the opposite uh really i think
it's essential uh that if and when we
vote to leave the european union i think
we should all seek to have david cameron
stay in office uh through what will be a
very important period of renegotiation
and you know i think that having that
degree of stability will be important
for the country and i don't need david
cameron to walk away uh overnight
because i think he's more responsible
than that i think he would know he'd
have a real commitment to the country
and a need to
make sure that we come through that that
period uh with maximum stability and
reassure everybody that we can do this
always great seeing you must end it
there mr brady thank you very much lee
graham brady there from the 1922
committee and you're watching monahan on
sky news coming up next